meantime in Elko County the Board of
Health considering a stop to covet and
flu vaccines this would also discontinue
all local advertising even advertising
for the vaccine this comes after Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis requested the
Florida Supreme Court investigate the
possible side effects of the vaccines
and then a group of Elko County
residents are also raising concerns the
Elko County Board of Health commissioner
John Carr thinks this shouldn't even
made it onto the agenda today
we don't have the authority to do this
even if we were 100 on board with it
where County Commissioners I think we're
a rather aggressive group and I'm proud
of what we've accomplished but if we
really wanted to vote in this I think
it'd be a huge overstep
so Carr thinks that an individual's
Health Care decision should be made on
their own and the county shouldn't be
making a decision for them when asked
about the vote he's still unsure if it
will be unanimous
in my understanding is that is basically
we believe in human rights of our
citizens and quite honestly our citizen
wants to go get a shot if they talk to
their doctor and know the pros and cons
then they're more than welcome and
should be able to
and I don't believe we should do a
moratorium getting a shot just like we
shouldn't do you have to go get the
shots so you can imagine this could
really have repercussions across the
state the Board of Health currently in
talks to move forward on the possibility
of stopping the vaccines so we're going
to have an update on this talk coming up
at 6 30 in our news there